part three of the absolute worst  roommate i ever had and how we got rid  of him so i'm paraphrasing a lot but  everything that went down took place  over the course of like six months we  had six months left in our lease and we  knew we just could not live like this  how did we get him to move out  basically we lied we sat down with him  and said look by throwing that party you  broke this section of our lease we  talked to the landlord we talked to my  parents lawyer and you need to move out  by the end of the month we're evicting  you now mind you none of this was true  we did talk to our landlord and explain  what was going on but legally there  there was no right we could not kick him  out basically we bluffed enough and just  scared him and he moved out so i  appreciated my other roommates more than  ever because none of us knew how bad it  could get